there's a manosphere convention what
what what is that
what is a manusphere hold on i gotta
find this now
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
a golden edge right now
you know when i was growing up i wanted
to be a ninja
i wanted to be a samurai i wanted to be
one of king arthur's nights oh why
wasn't i born
in a time like that that's how he talks
i guess yeah
why wasn't i born during the roman
empire
they have nothing is this andre the
giant
is andre the giant the leader of the
[ __ ] manuscripts
[Music]
what is this dude i'm today
nothing
my hands right now
infinite wealth infinitely transferable
push a button all the money moved all
the wealth moves
all the money moves the money moved to
bank account does the money move very
weird
you right actually use it you don't have
to change it
from gold to furs the wine to women
is it an accent is it a humongous tongue
is he
i think it's all three
plus a button is he someone goes is he
deaf
how easy is that
our life spans are extended i'm almost
50.
now you go back to 300 years ago how
would i look as a 50 year old
the advances in medicine technology well
skye
can't be a real person this feels like
this feels like like a mad tv skit right
location
all of that is the most phenomenal
spike in human history it's an
unparalleled opportunity
as men for every single one of you
there's a risk and there's always a
reward
now what are the things you're facing
think about the deeper threats
the phone has instant dopamine hits for
you oh my god this guy
imagine hanging out ivan
ivan thorne he's written some books um
let's see here best-selling author
and international speaker
his website says it's time to dominate
programs oh they have they have programs
crucial advice that allowed me to take
into the next level
moral disruption overthrow collapse
victorious respawn
emergency life intervention just as
forest fires clear out old deadwood
and free land and rebirth with new
growth there's a time in the life
of a man when burning everything down
and striding fresh and savage into
complete reframe is the only choice
ivan thorne has carefully designed a
very serious intervention program for
men who have made a replicable decisions
that have complete and utter rebuild of
their life absolutely and immediately
demanded with support from his
expertly trained team and carefully
gathered intelligence
your life can pivot instantly into power
moral disruption is a serious commitment
that requires
a post-purchase interview with the a
post-purchase interview
with the thorn dynamic team before you
start the program
how much is it how much is it
tell me how much it is oh no i get it
but dude come on give me let me see
let's say i want to buy
talk to us today
they don't even tell you how much it is
you have to do an assessment
so it looks like you've got to figure
out how much of a mark you are yeah
they squeeze you smart you do an
assessment
the world tumbles and collapses into
confusion
this on the website you must decide if
you was live this is serious or died
the day after christmas saturday
the 26th 2020 ivan will join me
as we walk you through the real secrets
of victory through dominance of your
heart
your mind and your hand dude they also
do fight training
i bet they're tough tough dudes what
will you learn from ivan
thorne and mr swift moral capacity
unleash the savage predator within
coherent manhood harness your total
human ferocity
competent dominance manage and profit
through power cycles
sustained leadership keeping the crown
of absolute victory
well let's see what happens if i try to
register reserve my place today
i can't i'm dude something's up because
they they're not showing any of their
prices yeah because they have to
[ __ ] yeah they're just squeezing
these people
[Music]
what separates there's none from you why
did they do it back then it was harder
food shelter well
oh you could be a viking in 2021 you
want to be a viking
no i play valheim before but viking look
at that that's what you're going to turn
into
a warrior i could just chill and play
valheim everything took so much work
well today
10 minutes from now i can be sitting
down with 15 000 calories in front of me
what separates you from these men think
about that
i don't know but i'm assuming that
vikings didn't have a webinar
and charge people six thousand dollars
of pop to go listen to their [ __ ] uh
to to go listen [ __ ] thor tell you a
speech
you're using the very system you're
making fun of and then why are you
glorifying the dark triad i mean that's
like
the horrible thing to be you know i
started
dogfight man and writing and speaking
almost three years sounds like you just
started speaking three years ago yes
that is correct
can we get somebody that speaks english
i just saw a speaker through
all before that all of the wolf
oh my god you think hulk hogan's gonna
body slam him
and it came after
a very somebody says it sounds like a
bunch of peanut butter in his mouth
something like that or dentist cotton
very challenging period in my life i was
up at about four o'clock in the morning
i woke up
i threw myself to the floor on my knees
and i asked what is it want me to do
he god wanted you to start a website
and charge men an absorbent amount of
money to tell them that
their powerful vikings i guess with how
is this different than scientology
because scientology has cool people in
it that's a good point
yeah those guys make movies there's
actually cool scientologists
yeah a screaming heartfelt player to
heaven
this is so corny two words
a lot
well what's the worst liar do you like
that uh that awesome uh epic
royalty-free music they're
yeah using going maybe three and a half
years ago
and i lied about how
i truly felt what i truly wanted
what i was truly capable of and not
capable of
and i've been playing this video for
five minutes
has he said anything but talk in a
circle
because he hasn't given any information
like he hasn't
taught you anything maybe if i skip
ahead
fundamental nature
of this creation that we're in
there's they model they hate this one
royalty-free skyrim music too
look at this dark triad man thing he
copyrighted it
of course mission that we're in
there's a model there's a process for
everything in this universe follows
breathing does a pulse of a cycle
breathing relationships
tantrums oh so it's not like personal
decisions you make it some sort of
cosmic
circus i
don't think that's how the world works
buddy
this is a cycle we're talking about
breathing we're talking about
flow about that pulse of things
things condense that
break and sink when they rise
they start dr scatter i gotta see some
of these comments
your second life begins when you realize
you only have one life
whoa yolo so you just basically took
yolo but made it way less easy to
remember
oh boy we just made yolo more
complicated
when they're cool they condense them
over
what the there's no one in this room who
doesn't know how to breathe
pay attention to yourself now
here's where this is important there is
a process to it
that follows one after the other
perception of the stage of where things
are
tells you where it's going that's where
the puck is going to be
okay understand that you want to be a
step ahead
that's the difference between leading
and reacting
between life and death survival
yeah i know the trains are going to be
heading to the camp i won't be here when
they leave
whoa whoa whoa was he talking about
i don't know how we got there how are we
very weird leap i know between life and
death
survival i know the trains are gonna be
heading to the camp
i won't be here when they leave
are you gonna save magneto
sometimes it's that simple so
each level of reality breathes it has
this pulse
learn to identify where it's at don't
fixate on it
because again any moment in the cycle
expansion the contraction expansion i
mean all this [ __ ] like and nobody just
goes yeah i have a question do you
really you really talk like that all the
time
like this isn't a bit
dude i got to know you [ __ ] with us i
mean i paid a lot of money to be here
that's fluid sounds like a skyrim yarl
with down syndrome
yeah you know what spending six thousand
dollars on this seminar is a lot better
than investing it in the [ __ ] stock
market and think about it
your life would be so much better if you
invested this money wisely
a little bring this axe to whiterun
and then if they bring if they get the
axe back
[ __ ] dragon shot over here freak
storm close like you're fired dude
what are you doing i gotta get somebody
else what are you doing
like a picture of a basketball player
at least the [ __ ] at least in the
game of thrones the mountain barely ever
talked for a reason
sure
when things are sinking
condense them what grows
cut what's condensing
and factor look i know i'm not a smart
guy
i will admit that i am not a genius in
any step in any way right
so i'll ask the chat even is he saying
anything
that is advice because it just seems
like he's reading fortune cookies
it sounds like he's reading nordic
fortunately
reading nordic fortune cookies he hasn't
given any advice
he's just kind of saying the universe is
expanding and contracting and
something about the what's what are we
doing
and what rachel's dragon what rages drag
what does that mean how do i apply that
to my life
how how can i put this in the plus let's
take a relationship
okay i'm ready my partner
uh does that look kind of like a
pentagram to you
this is a pentagram but with a bunch of
chinese [ __ ] around this guy sucks
what is this disgusting it's the same
thing all these guys do it's just a
bunch of babble and charts
and give me money this guy's like a
co-exist bumper sticker
that's the worst well if my woman
is latching on to an idea
i'm starting to become a little bit
unbridled
not helpful huh
this music just makes it so much worse
what do i do
oh our energy wow
bring in new things you melt with bottle
and
fire over metal is what they would say
without cutting what grows resistance is
rising in the villages
identify the leaders and kill them
tonight
we're killing people now uh duh
did you not know that
thank you carbon johnson nailed it he
goes
it's just esoteric jibber-jabber that's
what it is it's just
nothing he's just he's just uh kurt dude
a little with a speech impediment
yeah that's an extreme example
what are some examples in your own life
yes okay okay
look 11 minutes in we're now going to
see exam this is going to relate to us
now it took a while here we go all right
we got it
guys now we learn here we go you ready
how do you apply this to your own
goals
what do i want to do i don't know what
i'm going to be when i grow up
you know i have to figure something out
and scattered right well i'm kind of
interested in this
starts condensing down you start working
on it you master it
trying exhaustion
what huh what do i want to do next
what what do i do next what do i do
find out what yeah what does it
mean to say that as a human being i
am and all of you are made in the image
of god
i don't know what does that mean to you
i feel like i'm having a fever dream
about noses ears yeah okay
noses ears and hair i can't know what
those are not about body odor and
clothes
about a very specific thing every thug
that you have is a vision
of a future that you create
i hate this every thought that you have
is a vision of a future you create he's
babbling
what does that mean nothing but if again
if you're a [ __ ]
he can dazzle you and you'll give him
money
think and grow rich one way to put it
as you think so shall you be
you cannot have a thought that does not
shift the universe you could have a lot
of thoughts
that don't shift the universe you're
we're actually pretty inconsequential
when it comes to the [ __ ] universe
we're a bunch of [ __ ] apes with tvs
what are you talking
about that's our nature
every word that you speak is a vow
no it's not i want a hot dog is that a
vow
or maybe i just want a hot dog
you think jordy told me you think jordan
peterson's like this guy's
i don't know what this guy a bloody i
don't know what he's talking about it's
coming from me and i'm on pills
all you do is mumble
curse over a video game controller
are you sir are you
[Music]
casting aspersions about people mumbling
yeah i guess are you really gonna sit
there
speaking like an absolute [ __ ] and
you're going to tell me
that other people are mumbling
phone looking for another dopamine huh
what are you doing
i don't know i'm vowing that i want to
play video games for a little while yeah
maybe i just want to relax man maybe
i've had a tough week
can i just play video games
what is your expression of wealth in
this world
in this debt i figured it out this is
the new elder scrolls it's coming out
that's what this is this isn't okay that
makes sense ah
you're awake ah yes you're awake
same thing with deeds every deed is an
execution
[Music]
this is why video games are so seductive
infinite do-overs no consequence yeah
but a video game is 60 bucks it's not
six thousand dollar seminar
so if you spend 60 bucks and a video
game sucks like ah man a [ __ ] that sucks
if you spend six thousand dollars to
hear a mumbling giant tell you about
your viking ancestry
i'm gonna be pissed i'm gonna be really
[ __ ] angry
huh now i'm not saying video games are
bad and you should never play them
i'm not saying marijuana is bad you
should never smoke it although alcohol
the dangerous you should never drink
go find your own limits i hate this man
how dare this how dare this [ __ ] mush
mouth [ __ ]
tell anyone what to do okay what
like the fact that this [ __ ] decided
he was gonna get into a career of public
speaking makes me
violently angry what's happening
some people can't well
this guy being a public speaker is like
me coming in and going
so i'm gonna try out for the bucks next
year they're having a
they have an open tryout maybe the
jaguars it just
oh when they see bro you immediately get
a concussion when they see
how [ __ ] fast i am gronk runs into me
one time by the way not even on the
field just
accidentally in front of a vending
machine
and i'd have three concussions they'd go
how do you even get three concussions
from one fall
well because i hit gronk but then my
head hit the machine
and then it hit the ground so that's and
it was grunk high-fiving you just him
being nice hey man what's up buddy
they're just laying there next to a wet
floor sign and he's like
he just does this move like the family
guy the hands up and the just the back
away
he just goes oh boy i think we got a
problem
yeah i think one of those uh i think one
of those tryout guys in the whole way he
looks pretty bad
i don't know what happened he was like
that when i found him
[ __ ] i will tell you right now that if
i could do this for a living i mean you
could do primo whatever we want
is he doing this speech from underwater
it really does
just sound like never
ever going to escape it's like
hang on dude let me rip the duct tape
off
oh thank you god damn it so anyway like
i was saying you can unlock your
potential if you
holy [ __ ] she sounds like he's got duct
tape on his mouth he's been
of kidnapped thoughts your words and
your deeds
if there's a lie between them
you will have crash and you can't have
i love crabs the longer this goes on the
harder it is to hear what he's saying
ivan's lessons helped me focused on that
intrinsic
nature which holds better judgment i am
now prepared for my obstacles in my way
so he taught you also how to string
words together in a meaningless
structure that is just nothing it's just
nothingness
this is like if you feed what you feed
an ai a bunch of public speaking things
and they just come up with a seminar
why do i stress on this what's wrong
with just kicking back and casual and
then
not living a purposeful life
you only get one
i mentioned i'll be i'll be 48 this so
i'm almost 50. i'm aware
i will
it's like somebody put
like lennae d's speech impediment inside
of andre the giant yes
you're right yep so now i could no
longer say ohs
[ __ ] man that may not be as long as even
of the time i've had
hope so there's no guarantee that's
whimsical
okay also a lot of motorcycles so what
kind of humongous giant motorcycle
do you ride i also like that he slipped
that in it for no reason
well how else do you know he's cool i
mean are you trying to talk to the
audience you're trying to [ __ ] all of
these
that's pretty cool makes things a bit
more risky
do you have a death waiting for you
guarantee you
we know this cheesy stock footage that
he finds too and stuff this is so bad
coming what are you gonna do first
okay all right that that shot took way
too long
you had one day left to live you know
we'll hold on to resentment
and corrosion no i'd spend six thousand
dollars on a [ __ ] seminar
right yeah and bring that to your grave
you have time for that if you want a
fulfilled life
you must go deep you have to understand
that depth is important
yeah i know you have to dig you have to
work
wait i'm working towards dying because
that sounds pretty
hard for it i don't but i don't here's
the thing i mean i know i have to die
but i don't want to i'm not going to
work
towards it you're going to die
for work very hard for polly sock says
at this point
it sounds like someone's playing hans
zimmer over the audio of the adults from
the peanuts cartoon talking
it's terrible i mean and that's coming
from a a guy
who lives in poland and english is not
his second language
and i i've i've never had a problem
effortlessly understanding what
ballysong is saying i would rather
ballysong be giving this speech
this just in aw just signed him as a
commentator him or her belly song
both him and big show together on
commentary
at least bali's song will be up there
going you must to um
you must chase your dreams and in my
case it is making [ __ ]
with buried treasure underneath